[Music]
as soon as the tick came around
superhero parodies have become a dime a
dozen there's some real good ones
there's some real bad ones but bottom
line the shtick has been done to death
so if you're gonna do it you should have
a really damn good angle Megamind sort
of does it's nothing really that new
it's the superhero supervillain a damsel
in distress sort of taking on roles they
wouldn't usually take on so from a
comedic standpoint it doesn't really
work that great but from a dramatic
standpoint it actually has a few good
moments we have mega Mayan played by
Will Ferrell he's in the process of
tried to destroy a superhero played by
Brad Pitt by kidnapping his lady played
by Tina Fey all three of them have gone
through this schtick dozens of times the
hero always wins the villains thrown in
jail and the damsel is always rescued
that is except for one day when it
appears that Megamind actually wins yeah
he actually destroys the superhero ends
up taking over the world but he quickly
realizes taking over the world is kind
of boring now that he has it he doesn't
know what to do with it he has all the
power in the world but nobody to love
him he doesn't know how to feel or what
to do about it so he gets in contact
with Tina Fey again she of course tries
to stay away from him but over time she
starts to notice the true tragedy of the
character in fact even a very bizarre
sort of romance starts to form that is
until mega mine thinks he figures out
what he needs he tries to find an
everyday Schmo and give him superpowers
so that way he'll have an arch nemesis
yet again to fight but the downside is
the arch analysis actually doesn't want
to do good which forces Megamind to
ironically be the hero and once again
having to save the damsel in distress so
if you're familiar with superhero
knockoffs and parodies a lot of this is
pretty familiar and it's not unfunny
it's just maybe a little too familiar
we've seen it over and over again but it
is with still very likeable characters
Brad Pitt even has a pretty funny story
near the end about how he comes to a
conclusion about himself and how but
I'll enough most of the movie is source
spent in conversations mostly between
Megamind and the romantic lead
they're pretty good conversations l
admit I probably would like a few more
laughs out of this I mean I would like
to see a comedy but for these
conversations they're happy it's not bad
I actually do end up caring for both of
them and M sore curious where the
relationship between the two of them is
going to go the action in the movie is
good but not as good as some other
DreamWorks Animation let's not
characters get a few laughs but not
enough to take away focus from the main
characters I guess I really only have
two major problems with it one is yes I
could have used a lot more jokes I mean
it's a parody of superheroes there's so
much you can do with that and people
have done with that and I don't know I
just sort of feel like we got
Incredibles again taking what should be
a superhero comedy and making it
actually pretty serious but to be fair
from a different point of view and the
other thing is I find a little
distracting that Megamind becomes the
hero the hero becomes okay I won't give
it away but it's kind of the opposite
and the damsel becomes still the damsel
yeah that kind of bothered me I mean
yeah she goes through a change and that
she sort of becomes interest in Megamind
but come on we're really gonna hang her
off the tower again we're really gonna
do this whole shtick you were doing so
good and making her an interesting
character and then you just go Mary Jane
on our asses why couldn't she be the
hero I may be the superhero the villain
and maybe Megamind the person has to be
saved you know some sort of switch of
that made sense and equaled out I don't
know to me it just seemed like a big
missed opportunity but for what we did
get I think Megamind was a cute film I'd
say it certainly has more adult moments
than other DreamWorks movies in that
well there's a lot of sitting down and
talking but like I said I think the
characters are enjoyable enough to
listen to and you even get pretty
wrapped up in their drama I don't think
it's a grand film in terms of superhero
flicks or even the emotional dramas but
it's not bad I came out glad to know
that the characters I want to be okay
came out okay not a great film but a
good one I'd say it's definitely worth
checking out
[Music]
you